[Music]
it's so nice to have you here and i i
went backstage to say hello and uh your
brother was hanging out with you my
brother's here somewhere where is he is
your brother here he's hanging out uh is
he out here on the stage because he was
oh there he is hi where is he up there
there he is i'm glad we didn't make fun
of him at the front of the show
you were in a bit you were under a label
at the front there yeah the label things
yeah no i don't think we did that to him
we would never do that he was under
label but that's okay get over it
we um
[Music]
what is your brother's name we should
give him a name mcgregor
good to see you
he is a lieutenant you said yes he was
in the royal air force he flew tornado
bomber jets for um 20 years oh my
goodness yeah well he didn't fly those
jets for 20 years but he was in the raf
for 20 years all right for 20 years did
he ever take you up in one of those jets
yes he did yeah we i was very fortunate
because it's impossible to get a
backseat ride in a fast jet military jet
in britain anyway but because we were
both associated with the charity in
scotland the children's hospice
association of scotland we were both
raising money for them this year so the
raf
let me fly with him and it was an
amazing experience because i've i've
never seen my brother at work he's seen
all my work right but i'd never seen him
at his work you know so i got in the
back of this jet and
we didn't
it's just it's just the two of us and
you can't really see him because there's
a radar in front of you is that is that
a military secret that i've just given
away yes you have
yeah bite down on your taps or sign
something yeah yeah so there's something
in front of your face there that you
can't you should just see a bit of his
helmet on that side on that side yeah
and the canopy goes down and then we
took off we did a lap of we did a lap of
scotland in like an hour and 20 minutes
the whole country it was really amazing
because you must be going incredibly
fast very very fast very low and makes
you very very sick
the g-force is unbelievable you can't
you can't i like to make an excuse for
myself here is you can't see the corner
coming right so you're just flying along
and then suddenly you're in a corner
like that the g-force is pushing you
back in the seat and you know a lot of
when people go up with the blue angels
the pilots try and make them yeah throw
up did was your brother trying to make
you throw i don't know were you trying
to make him throw up
no no we did the first but first we took
off we did like
10 15 minutes really low level down
glenn's and it's unbelievable going on
where are you going were you like taking
people's clothes off the laundry line we
were way below the level of the
mountains i mean you're right down in
the valley in the glens i don't know 200
200 feet oh my god
how fast 400 miles an hour yeah really
fast of scary scary stuff but really
amazing this is clearly something you're
not allowed to do and now you're being
outed
he's thinking further and further and
then we went and we robbed that bank
and then we shot those people with a
machine gun
they were asking for it though they were
asking